brett to start with you
um your character helly is definitely
someone i would argue comes in and
shakes things up a little bit um you
know for the group um
and and definitely does not want to stay
there but can't seem to quit
her position in spite of attempts so
what do you think is primarily fueling
her motivation to kind of disrupt the
status quo so to speak
uh yeah so heli wakes up on an office
table having no clue who she is and i
think
not knowing is what becomes the engine
to her wanting to escape to get to the
outside and find out who she is at core
and initially she thinks it's the boss
and the system that are keeping her
trapped inside of this place that she
doesn't want to be but when she
discovers that it's actually herself on
the outside
i think it becomes this really
poignant uh
poignant um
way of highlighting that we're often our
own worst enemy so she becomes this
human versus self uh embodiment
john i was i think especially moved by
irving's ark this season you play
somebody who i think we can argue is
more of a stickler for company rules you
know recites the can book
by memory but then ends up break i would
say maybe breaking some rules himself um
when he meets someone what was something
that you wanted to convey in terms of
the relationship and how meaningful that
becomes for irving i think you know
even if you reduce someone to a
child-like state there's there's still
an innate uh need
and longing to connect with another
person and i thought that was something
that was really interesting to me
especially coming from a very
disciplined
background which you
it touches on right at the end uh so i
thought that was
really it's that's a universal thing and
that they they can't erase you
completely and uh and then his
the dawning of that while he's there and
i thought that was something
uh especially that i got to do that with
christopher uh it was uh
it was it was interesting it was
interesting and i think very human
too
for sure um zach for you
dylan has all of these wild and
hilarious theories that he comes up with
for what lumen is actually doing what
their jobs entail were there ever any
alternative pretend theories that were
decided on or something that you think
dylan would have come up with after
spending long hours at that cubicle i
think he he
could come up with almost anything and
would believe almost anything because he
really has no idea what's going on and
he also until heli arrives doesn't
really care that much like he he has a
lot of questions and he likes
talking about it and he likes telling
stories about what might be going on but
until helly shows up he it kind of
doesn't affect his day-to-day life he's
like it doesn't matter i still gotta hit
my numbers so
i think he would maybe believe almost
anything
um that's actually all the time i have
but thank you all so much for sitting
with me talking about the show it's a
wild ride and i cannot wait for everyone
else to see it and i am crossing my
fingers very hard for a season two
already so thank you so much
thanks
you